oi meu nome é lara e hoje eu vou falar
sobre a biodiversidade ea proteção ante
leve e natural
você sabe que a biodiversidade big bill
significa seres vivos diversidade e
variedade então de diversidade significa
a variedade de seres vivos dentro dela
contém animais e vegetais fungos e
microorganismos
quando nós temos a biodiversidade nós
temos um equilíbrio ambiental quando nós
temos a monocultura ou seja o último de
uma única espécie
nós temos um desequilíbrio ambiental o
que significa significa que china e
disse nós temos um jardim com uma única
espécie de flor menor vai ter o
equilíbrio ambiental ou seja menor a
terminar a biodiversidade quanto esse
nós tivemos um jardim com várias
espécies de flores maior o equilíbrio
ambiental ou seja muito maior à
biodiversidade
aqui é uma pequena taxa da
biodiversidade aqui do brasil
agora alguns fatores reduzem a
biodiversidade o que está acontecendo
principalmente aqui no brasil é a
redução da biodiversidade como as
queimadas ea poluição mais gilz objetivo
nas plantações e principalmente o
desmatamento
alguns de vocês sabem o que se conhece
tem a ver com a biodiversidade é bem
simples
existem dois tipos de chiclete o
chiclete sintético que é produzido por
uma substância do petróleo e chiclete
natural que é produzido pela seita
chamada chico e da área de saúde que
cresce e vive nas florestas tropicais do
méxico chamado yucatán vendendo
lembrando que essas aves não só não são
cultivadas aqui no brasil apenas no
méxico
quem é buscar essa semana são chico
coelhos
eles apenas fazem
nas áreas de riscos nas rádios para não
prejudicar o meio ambiente
mas os madeireiros estão indo nessas
florestas estão cortando as árvores para
fazer móveis e outras coisas
e além de estar tirando emprego dos
chicleteiros está reduzindo demais a
biodiversidade
bom depois que chicão é tirar da árvore
é mandado para uma fábrica e passa a se
chamar boa base com ele mas alguns
ingredientes conseguimos fazer o
chiclete natural
alguns desses ingredientes são o xarope
de milho o açúcar o corante e o aroma
bom o que eu quero dizer na minha
apresenta a mensagem que eu quero passar
na minha apresentação é que nós podemos
usar a biodiversidade só não precisamos
reduzi la
obrigado pela participação de 2